the horrors of the Ukraine war are still
raging and maybe for months or years to
come but bringing the perpetrators of
war crimes to Justice doesn't need to
wait
the government's top lawyer told me
about the Intensive training the UK is
giving to 90 Ukrainian judges at a
secret location in the region to help
them convict Russian soldiers they are
Prosecuting war crimes in real time this
is a live and very brutal conflict I
hope that those Russian soldiers and
officers who are watching the Ukrainian
prosecutions at the moment will realize
that they must act in accordance with
international law most war crimes will
be tried in Ukraine but its president is
also pushing for an international
tribunal modeled on the Nuremberg trials
the aim is to have prosecutions at all
levels isn't it the rank and file
soldiers but also the Russian top
generals and maybe one day Vladimir
Putin the International Community will
want to have a moment where Justice is
done and seen to be done we don't yet
know exactly what form that will take I
I don't think when I was a government
lawyer that we ever anticipated that we
would have
war crimes in Europe in the way that
that we did
um again
in the second world war and and that we
would have to start talking about
Nuremberg style trials Sky News teams
have witnessed the sort of atrocities
for which it is hoped Russian leaders
will eventually be held accountable
like these killings in macarieve on the
outskirts of Kiev where officials say
over 130 bodies were found they've never
tried war crimes before and it's a
specialized business sir Howard Morrison
a former judge at the international
criminal court in The Hague spoke to us
after his first session with the
Ukrainian judges
25 years staring either literally or
metaphorically into Mass Graves and
believe you me it's a very different
exercise than a single body or a single
victim so far Ukrainian authorities have
convicted 14 Russian soldiers the number
of cases recorded is more than 43 000.
the ball is rolling but it will take
time money and political will to reach
the bigger targets